foreign
[Music]
streets are getting covered in body
parts and we're sitting on our hands how
many dead 20. I need you Israel needs
you
with every bomb a message is sent to our
people each time to send a message of
Our Own
[Music]
business no one has to know we're there
I go
es guys something's happening
tell me what you're doing here Avi right
outside Gaza with the U.S senator
what's going on yeah the bombing in
Jerusalem five minutes ago the engineer
that's our Target all hands on deck
teaching them how to make bombs the
bombs may be sophisticated
strategy in these attacks we need to
think like Mad Men
you don't scare me well I'm trying to
scare you I'm just trying to prepare you
I'm already prepared to die we'll see
about that
[Music]
all right
this is all our fight brother
we gotta find a way into the house
who's the engineer he's here
[Applause]
I need a visual before you disappeared
good
[Music]
[Applause]